I sent out a tweet which I normally you
know don't and so I sent out two here's
the tweet here's the tweet that I
actually sent up
it was to the notorious MMA which is
Connor I said stay outside the first
three rounds don't overcommit strikes
mostly jabs get booed by the crowd
doesn't matter frustrate frustrate could
be force bad shots tire him out in the
fourth start stepping up the striking in
the fifth let it go and finish him good
luck John Kavanagh at John Kavanagh I
tagged his coach because his coach well
okay no people are going okay well why
are you rooting for Conor McGregor and
some people went like a little crazy
like why are you when he's a bad sets a
bad example for the sport and all that
and so actually the reason is because
I've communicated with Coach Cavanaugh a
decent amount on Twitter and little DMS
and all that and just you know he just
has been kind of like a cool guy and
here he was going in to coach his
fighter in the biggest fight of of
Connors life and you know just because
we've had that little converse that
we've had conversations on Twitter a
bunch and I just threw that out there
like two hours before I mean we I was
watching the first fights when I threw
that out there and you know what the
really funny thing is John Kavanagh
texted back or he tweeted back copy so
he actually read it and responded which
is pretty crazy so so anyways because I
have had a little interaction with coach
John Kavanagh I felt like you know hey
off of us out there also you know Hans
sure Hans is like boys with Conor right
and Hans is my boy so I was you know
that that association there's
Association you know I'm gonna make hey
Hans is my boy and he has been for a
long time and he's bros with Conor and
so I just you know like again so so
people are why did you why you
for this guy when so there's that whole
thing now the the the other odd thing
about this is you have a striker versus
a grappler who do I root for in striker
versus of grappler grab I always root
for the grappler and I know that
factually and statistically the grappler
has the advantage because grappling
versus striking the grappler wins most
of the time how can you go the distance
with this argument sure you can took at
all the people that all the times that a
striker is actually a good grappler and
then they don't use their grappling but
they use their grappling only to defend
from being taken down Chuck Liddell then
there's a bunch of other there's
countless guys that you can now name
that knocked people out and people were
known for their stand-up but what they
really were their base was that they
were a good restaurant couldn't be taken
down so but generally striker versus
grappler the striker and this is what I
talk about from a self-defence
perspective right if a if you're a good
striker then that means you can run away
the end and if you're a good grappler
once you get a hold of someone you can
defeat someone that has good striking
here's the thing that people to
understand in order for you to punch
someone you have to get close enough for
them that where they can take you down
you have to get into their takedown
ranch the ridge so you have to get in
the redzone so once you're in the red
zone you can get taken down so how do
you defeat that as a as a striker how do
you defeat a really good grappler the
way you do it is by doing what I just
said you stay on the outside you you
touch person up you don't overcommit you
shirk because the harder you notice how
many rounds have you done of MMA
sparring countless okay me too so it
when I would be going against a striker
the harder they throw at you the easier
it is to take him down all day long and
when I'm going against a wrestler that I
don't want to get taken down against
like I used to do this to Dean then just
frustrate him not commit to any punches
not throw any kicks at all sit there in
jab and run away for basically two or
three rounds and even Dean who's a far
superior wrestler to me
would have a very very hard time taking
me down yeah so this is a legit strategy
the reason I know it's a legit strategy
is because people have used it against
Dean when Dean was fighting MMA people
used that particular strategy against
him and it worked
mm-hm and so I know the strategy works
guys that Dean was infinitely better on
on the ground mm-hm and yet he couldn't
take him down and he was infinitely
better at wrestling why could he take
him out because they weren't playing
that game they weren't playing they
weren't even playing the MMA game they
were playing the I'm gonna jab you and
stay away